allora quando sono stato invitato con
piacere a fare per tenere questo talk
oggi il tema erano maliano e quindi
stiamo pensando un po e noi ci occorre
di salute digitale quindi sono le
anomalie genetiche ci sono le anomalie
nei processi di innovazione eccetera per
poi ragionando un po abbiamo pensato che
noi siamo un'anomalia cioè l'azienda che
abbiamo fondato healthware e il percorso
abbiamo fatto per più di vent'anni è
effettivamente una somma di tantissime
anomalie quindi ci è venuta l'idea di
raccontarle gli errori le cose che
magari sono andate bene un po varie cose
non normali che negli anni sono successi
e forse da questo derivare delle idee o
magari degli avvisi ai naviganti per non
replicare gli errori per chi sta facendo
una start up per chi sta facendo partire
la nuova azienda per chi sta facendo
partivano avventura quello spirito di
questo di questo talk è questo qua
allora io sono nato a napoli e adesso
vivo a salerno viaggio tantissimo da
sempre e napoli non è una città nota
della tecnologia non è una città nota
per l'innovazione soprattutto più di
venti anni fa e questo me ne sono
accorto molto presto ne sono accorto
quando cominciavano a frequentare milano
e ricordo ancora un primo business
meeting importante in realtà a bologna
era pomeriggio e mi dicono anzi alla
fine mattinata e mi dicono ok guarda
benissimo però purtroppo non ho tempo
avevo aspettato del parere questa
persona tipo 4 ore milo incontro lui con
tutte queste persone attorno capo di
un'importante azienda mi dice guarda tu
sei uno fantastico però mini parte il
volo ci vediamo domani mattina a milano
panico perché ora bologna avevo il treno
per tornare giù e la mattina dopo a
milano era un problema e quindi mi
ricordo che chi ha parlato prima mie di
fumetti ha parlato del treno che faceva
napoli milano durante la notte che ho
preso anche io per arrivare all
appuntamento a milano fresco con una
rosa dopo l'espresso di cui di cui sopra
e la cosa è andata avanti negli anni la
prima volta che sono arrivato a parigi
per una
nuovo incarico un nuovo progetto
volevano essere green come mi saluti di
roberto bene e da dove vieni stamattina
no io guarda sono partito da salerno mi
fanno a è ok e quindi come era il tempo
stamattina a milano io un'attrice ma
perché salerno non è in provincia di
milano
no salerno non è in provincia di milano
informo che in un altro post sul mare
eccetera bene a quel momento decidiamo
con un'astuta mossa di marketing di
scrivere a salerno amalfi coast come
luogo di riposizionamento dell'azienda
che da quel momento invece ogni volta
che le persone a lui e che cio
fighissimo quindi siete sulla costiera
amalfitana si siamo proprio all'inizio
della costiera amalfitana bene potrei
raccontare tante ma abbiamo ovviamente
un tempo da rispettare da dove è nato
tutto è nato da quando avevo circa 10 11
anni e
sostanzialmente incappa in un amico a
cui avevano regalato un comodo 64 che
era ovviamente chi non lo sa uno dei
primi un computer come si diceva allora
che avevano un prezzo per cui si
potevano effettivamente comprare
abbastanza serenamente e questa cosa la
trovai fantastica e quindi insomma
cercare di averne uno anch'io i miei
genitori
melo regalarmi però non mi colpì quello
che devo dire partiva il discorso di
videogiochi eccetera impazzì
letteralmente per quello che poi capi
erano linguaggi di programmazione e in
particolare quello che vedete lì sopra
che hanno un linguaggio che si chiamava
logo e che era molto semplice si
trattava di dare delle istruzioni a una
tartaruga virtuale che disegnava e
poteva ruotare su se stessa quindi
settori dice vai avanti tutto passi fai
una linea ruota di 90 gradi facevi
questo e potevi costruire delle forme
dei quadrati
eccetera eccetera e ovviamente se facevi
più di queste istruzioni potevi
disegnare qualsiasi cosa e quindi questa
cosa era per me una roba incredibile per
quello dell'immaginare della robe
scrivere quello che poi ho capito dopo
sarebbe stato un software per disegnare
delle cose a rappresentare quindi delle
cose è sostanzialmente perché è
importante perché mentre tutti si
occupavano tutti insomma giocavano ed e
si aggregavano anche in realtà noi ci
troviamo con tre quattro amici che
invece erano appassionati per la
programmazione
ognuno di questi ha fondato un'azienda
ora sono tutte alcune sono addirittura
addirittura quotato in borsa e anche noi
abbiamo fondata una il ricordo
distintamente che quando chiesi di
comprare il computer ai miei genitori li
senti parlare da lontano perché
ovviamente mancare una spesa in famiglia
e ricordo che uno dei due non ricordo
chi disse forse un errore comprarlo
perché vedi che passa tanto tempo a
scrivere questi software e ricordo che
l'altra risposta fu va bene magari uno
sbaglio
e poi c'è tempo per tornare indietro e
quindi ho capito allora anzi o meglio
capito negli anni che il permesso di
sbagliare una cosa fondamentale e questa
è una cosa che noi cerchiamo di fare
tanto anche in azienda naturalmente
perché il permesso di sbagliare che mi
diede meader un i miei
ci ha portato poi a capire quello che
sarebbe successo dopo
e questo è andato avanti nel tempo
quando si è deciso per esempio cosa
avrei dovuto studiare ovviamente io come
tutti in italia sono andato alle scuole
medie le scuole medie alla fine finivano
che ti davano una non serve una pagella
comunque un giudizio e una
raccomandazione su cosa doveva fare dopo
allora io alle scuole medie è andato
benino questo andato molto male dopo e
quindi alle scuole medie alla fine c'era
il giudizio e quindi io prima avevano
chiesto tutti vuoi fare dopo io allora
facevo il software e quindi si voglia
andare all'istituto tecnico di
informatica perché dove li mi ero
informato si faceva si faceva software e
la cosa molto molto divertente fu che
quando dissi questa cosa
nella nel professoressa insomma ci fu un
po di un po di un po di sgomento e nel
giudizio finale ricordo ancora ce l'ho
ancora conservato c'era scritto beh
presi mi pare si diceva ottimo c'erano
delle parole non ero numeri e mi dissero
si raccomandano studi classici e
scientifici tra parte certamente non
l'istituto tecnico che il ragazzo
reiteratamente suggerisce ovviamente a
dall'istituto tecnico a studiare questa
informatica e poi dopo due anni
l'istituto tecnico
uno mi disse se tu veramente vuoi fare
l'informatica parliamo di oltre 20 anni
fa
devi sapere alla filosofia profilo e
scoprire la filosofia non si faceva nel
triennio del suo tecnico quindi ministro
studiare il latino e andargli alla luce
il liceo scientifico dove poi non ho
fatto niente per tre anni e questo mi ha
dato un sacco di tempo libero per
continuare a programmare e la filosofia
mela sono studiata da solo nel tempo e
un'altra anomalia del percorso che mi
piace che mi piace raccontare è
collegata a un camper papa che un medico
e che neanche lui è normale o meglio ha
fatto un sacco di cose al contrario dopo
che si lavora di medicina
ogni due tre anni chiudeva lo studio
medico perdendo tutti i pazienti
naturalmente per andare a passare tre
quattro mesi in inghilterra
all'epoca si andava in inghilterra a
studiare medicina almeno quella branca
della medicina e durante i mesi estivi
ci portava con sé e si andava con il
camper e quindi si passavano dei periodi
con il camper in in in londra e papà
ovviamente faceva 12 ore in ospedale e
noi si stava lì e quindi se ci si è
imparato un po di inglese si andava un
po in giro eccetera però perché è molto
importante questo importante perché
intanto era abbastanza anomalo fare le
vacanze ogni tot anni non sempre lì dove
facciamo un po freddo e dove non si
andava al mare ma in una di queste stati
successe che è un po io mi annoiavo e
quindi a un certo punto lui che vedeva
che io bazzicavo con con il software si
industria per trovare qualcuno che nello
spedale lì si occupasse di software e
quindi una mattina mi dice guarda
andiamo a vedere dei ragazzi che fanno
software ma nello spedale e io dissi
baffigo andiamo andai lì questi
ovviamente non era una cosa come si dice
auto blu non era previsto niente non è
che io fossi lì era un ragazzino con le
mie quattro però in inglese dissi ho
saputo che fate software nello spedale
io faccio software mi piacerebbe capire
e questi che cosa facevano erano un
gruppetto che faceva le prime cose di
software applicati a migliorare i
processi di un ospedale in particola
questi ragazzi scrivevano programmini
per aiutare gli studenti medicina era un
ospedale ovviamente universitario a
ridurre il numero di esami inutili che
questi ragazzi prescrivevano perché
ovviamente da giovani studenti
prescrivevano tutti e questa cosa per me
fu una folgorazione di sé capperi quindi
si possono fare queste cose si possono
scrivere the software che si occupano
che si occupa di medicina perché
ovviamente ero cresciuto e una famiglia
con mio padre e quindi naturalmente
avevo questo osmosi di questa questa
questa sensazione questa questo
interesse questo interesse per la
medicina è quindi quello fu un momento
veramente di realizzazione
figlio di una cosa completamente strana
stare lì
con il camper mentre papà faceva lo
studio continuo nel tempo
in queste stati dove non c'era il mare
però poi si era creata questa occasione
di andare a fare a scrivere software in
un ambito che mi sembrava molto utile e
quindi venne questa idea di dire beh
però questi due mondi
in effetti hanno tanto a che vedere
potrebbero avere tanto a che vedere uno
con l'altro parliamo ovviamente di tanto
tempo fa si che facciamo un salto in
avanti
finisco gli studi e che cosa faccio dico
mi iscrivo a medicina perché tanto
pensavo programmare so programmare se
voglio scrivere software per la medicina
bisogna che sia medico ovviamente
chiunque mi disse che era un errore
perché non è che tu studi per fare il
medico per andare poi a fare il questo
tipo questo tipo di lavoro lo feci e
ovviamente non ho fatto il medico ho
fondato healthware da healthcare
software con l'idea di scrivere software
per la medicina per migliorare come la
medicina funzione
partimmo con un po di soldi prestati da
mamma e papà e cene vergognavamo o meno
ergon chiamo perché all'epoca non era
così figo oggi si dice se è stato
bootstrap da friends and family e fa
figo della madonna e poi ai ovviamente
il funding del sid fund che erano un po
di soldi che ho preso in banca è un po
meglio di prima però è ancora e ancora
tosta e bisogna pianificare molto avanti
e questo l'ho imparato molto presto nel
tempo c'è qui fulvio che lavora come
ormai da vent'anni è praticamente un
cofondatore di hell to air perché quando
lui è arrivato eravamo una banda di
disperati che facciamo software ea un
certo punto io cercavo qualcuno per
mettere ordine in casa e quindi lui
venne e aveva un background già vede
sette persone e mi dice beh allora dai
tu che cosa vuoi fare allora io gli
faccio vedere su una lavagna un
organigramma che c'erano 30 caselle
allora lui ascolta la mia spiegazione e
poi mi dice scusami una sola domanda
presso tutto chiaro ci sono 30 caselle e
sette persone così perché quello ne fa 5
io ne faccio 6
bari e fai questi 8 e da allora ha si è
aggiunto al treno ed è diventato anche
lui una locomotiva non si può fare
niente da soli questo signore qui si è
inventato la comunicazione sanitaria in
italia quello ovviamente non io
e nel tempo ci ha aiutato a comprendere
nuovi livelli nuovi mondi nuove nuove
possibilità e non ho avuto nessun
problema a essere il migliore di tutti
a milano perfettamente di grande
successo nel suo ambito ea raccogliere
noi che venivamo da giu trattandoci
completamente da paris questa è stata
una cosa è inestimabile per la nostra
crescita
allearsi e importante ma lo devi fare
sempre con persone che hanno il tuo
stesso tratto culturale questo signore
che vedete la foto è un amico più
recente si chiama farouk e il ceo della
più grande società americana che fa lo
stesso lavoro che facciamo noi in europa
ed è turco ed è arrivato i migranti e
gli stati uniti al fondato a kansas city
questa società che poi si è espansa
chicago new york san francisco
dappertutto e proprio pochi giorni fa a
kansas city ha celebrato il loro
ventennale e la cosa divertente è che ha
raccontato la sua storia mi dice sai io
la prima volta che andavo a new york che
significano ma tu che fai che viene a
kansas city e proprio quell accento così
strano mi ha ricordato esattamente
quello che succedeva a noi
inutile dire che la collaborazione
funziona veramente molto bene
il team per anni per i primi anni
abbiamo cercato di prendere le persone
che erano come dovevano essere cioè
strutturati esattamente per quello che
dovevano fare e abbiamo avuto parecchi i
fallimenti per a un certo punto abbiamo
capito che invece dovevamo cercare le
attitudini e non guardare a quello che
erano un normale nei percorsi e allora
abbiamo cominciato a tornare economisti
che però sono appassionati di design e
persone che hanno studiato antropologia
filosofia che però si vogliono occupare
di economia persone che vengono da tutti
altri ambiti e poi sono nell'ambito
creativo e questo ha creato un team che
non sarà perfetto ma vi assicuro che è
uno dei migliori del mondo
ancora un paio di cose nella avviandoci
verso verso la fine nel tempo ho capito
che è molto importante saper cogliere le
occasioni e anche se queste occasioni
sono apparentemente estranee a questa è
una storia che sono un po così
noi nel frattempo la società l'avevamo
eravamo stati acquisiti come si dice da
un grande gruppo internazionale
allora mi arriva una telefonata dal capo
supremo di giovedì sera e mi dice vuoi
gestire un ufficio una struttura negli
stati uniti
e io dico non lo so di che cosa si
occupano e lui mi ripetevo e gestire una
struttura negli stati uniti
allora io riprovo ma quante personesono
dove stanno
ma tu la vuoi gestirlo a sud si a quel
punto sì allora io dico quindi fa va
bene ti faccio sapere
mi richiama dopo mezz'ora e mi dice
allora tutto fatto
bisogna che ti presenti in ufficio negli
stati uniti per prendere possesso di
questa struttura e poi vedi che vi fa
quando si parte non mi organizzo certo
era giovedì sera ci guarda e
l'appuntamento è lunedì mattina alle 9 a
e in iowa nel nel centro gli stati uniti
non per nulla neanche a facile da
raggiungere
allora panico mi metti un aereo vado là
e primo incarico negli stati uniti
dovevo parlare a tutta questa serie di
persone al posto del loro capo grassa di
loro capo per 15 anni prima
voi potete immaginare il livello di
accoglienza che ricevette in
quell'occasione allora andai lì è
chiaramente dissi bene a questo punto
non posso pretendere di aver fatto l'en
di qua o là o aver fatto questo quell
esperienza quindi mi presentai con una
bella chart vengono a napoli e pensare a
delle cose dei visual crew che erano
chiaramente familiari e quindi la pizza
no il maradona e quant'altro e
funzionano alla grande perché alla fine
ho capito che tutto sommato ognuno ha
una sua diciamo così eccellenza e è
molto importante comunque connettersi a
quella però ci torno nella nel finale
tra poco l'avventura agli stati uniti e
continuate quindi a certo punto siamo
arrivati a new york e quando arrivi a
new york sono arrivi a new york
e allora mi volevano incoraggiare questo
incarico a new york
e mi dico guarda tu sei veramente molto
bravo e hai dimostrato di essere un
ottimo attore non a broadway adesso però
è tutta un'altra cosa devi dimostrare di
essere un grande attore a broadway
ok non è che mi sentivo molto
incoraggiato in quel momento sentendo
questa cosa però ho capito una cosa
molto importante negli anni che ci sono
dei livelli di gioco non è che quando
passi dalla serie b alla serie a nel
calcio cambiano le regole cambiano i 90
minuti cambiano le 11 persone ci sono
delle piccole cose non delle grandi cose
che però fanno un po la differenza e
quindi nel tempo riuscire a capire che
queste differenze di colmare ti devi
mettere a quelli del il gioco è
sicuramente molto importante
a un certo punto noi da quel grande
gruppo siamo usciti e siamo ritornati
essere un'azienda indipendente perché
questo è interessante perché tutte le
società che fanno il percorso abbiamo
fatto noi cioè di acquisizione fanno la
cosiddetta exit come si come si dice in
terminologia attuale non tornò mai
indietro
noi siamo tornati indietro cioè
esattamente la società che fu comprata e
uscita poi da questo gruppo ed è
ritornato a una società indipendente e
questa cosa ha dato luogo a un nuovo
ciclo che è ripartito dal 2015 di
successo ganau mai avuto prima e abbiamo
capito tante cose
una che è molto importante celebrare i
propri successi così come riflettere
chiaramente sulle sconfitte questa una
bellissima foto della festa abbiamo
fatto per il ventennale di euro al
castello di arechi qui a salerno con
amici da tutto il mondo le persone di
tutti i vari uffici europei che ancora
ci ricordiamo l'atmosfera di quella sera
eccetera perché questo è importante
perché bisogna essere molto bravi a
celebrare i successi molto bravi
analizzare le sconfitte e da tutte e due
le cose trovare energia o insegnamenti e
allora andando verso la conclusione
che cosa è successo da quel momento in
poi
da quel momento in poi sono successe
tante cose e ovviamente come sempre ci
sono cose che sono andate bene cosa sono
andate meno bene ma la cosa più
importante non è tanto questa è quella
che è venuto fuori un libro che racconta
di come stiamo cercando di dare il
nostro piccolo contributo a cambiare la
salute sono venute opportunità che prima
neanche riuscivamo a immaginare tutte
figlie di aver preso la decisione più
inaspettata possibile la prima azienda
del nostro settore che ha fatto questo
percorso all'incontro si è resa
indipendente dall'indipendenza ora è più
grande di quando ha lasciato un porto
diciamo così più sicuro e tra le tante
cose che sono successe dal 2015 ad oggi
una è molto legata a dove siamo oggi la
città di la città di salerno
ricordate quando sono partito dalle
geografie e parlando di napoli e
eccetera
un'altra cosa che abbiamo capito nel
tempo e che l'abbiamo sentito anche
prima intanto in altre in altre forme
bisogna costruire sulle diversità
bisogna costruire sulle diversità perché
in un mondo iperconnesso aver accelerato
esponenziale alcuni dicono eccetera
in realtà è il diverso che si va a
cercare il diverso dove c'è il
potenziale diverso ovviamente fatto in
un certo modo ma non abbiamo tempo per
descrivere bene noi che cosa abbiamo
fatto abbiamo avuto l'opportunità di
affittare quindi un normale affitto un
edificio
il complesso monumentale di santa sofia
per chi di salerno sasà dove è nato il
palazzo innovazione ed è una cosa che
abbiamo finanziato noi
e molti mi hanno chiesto ma perché lo
fai lo facciamo perché con questa
con questa iniziativa noi abbiamo dato
un reason why fortissimo per essere qui
oltre quello che ovviamente storicamente
c allegata ecco pensate che nel primo
anno di vita di palazzo innovazione dove
abbiamo messo anche un centro ovviamente
per la salute digitale sono venute oltre
duemila persone da 15 paesi diversi ed
oggi aziende da tutto il mondo start up
vengono qui perché perché riescono a
concentrarsi 2 3 giorni e fare degli
sprint come si dice delle sessioni
interattive le sezioni co creation in un
posto che è magico perché è un ex
monastero dell'undicesimo secolo che è
diventato un polo di innovazione
internazionale e lo abbiamo chiamato
palazzo innovazione anche se ciò
campagnacci o innovazione o palazzo e
quant'altro di cui andiamo ovviamente
molto fieri e allora vi lascio con la
riflessione che ho un po accennato
veramente tante tante tante cose che non
erano previste tante cose che erano un
po anomali come il titolo il tema di
questo di questo ted tante scelte che
apparentemente erano o troppo rischiose
o controllati anche magari stupide
in realtà hanno dato vita ad un'azienda
a una comunità di persone a tante
persone che hanno poi realizzato dei
progetti su questo ha cosi fisiche come
il palazzo innovazione che ho citato
prima e tante altre cose che succedono
tutte attorno a noi quello che voglio
dirvi è che tutte queste cose che
apparentemente sono anomale strane non
convenzionali inopportune accelera
intenti o di incertezza oppure tempi di
grandi cambiamenti come sono quelli che
stiamo vivendo in questi anni in realtà
sono una miniera inesauribile di
opportunità
la cosa più importante di tutte e
costruirci sopra in modo che siano
chiaramente comprensibili agli altri
altrimenti questo diciamo questa questa
chimica questa magia non si attiva
ma sono sostanzialmente una grandissima
ricchezza e queste anomalie ci sono
dappertutto quindi la verità vera è che
c'è posto per tutti nella vita nel
business nelle attivita che si vogliono
fare
c'è posto per tutti c'è posto per tutti
i luoghi e c'è posto per tutte quante le
idee a patto chiaramente di impegnarsi a
fondo nella realizzazione delle stesse
questo è quello che la nostra diciamo
storia rappresenta e ci è sembrato il
modo migliore di connetterci al tema
delle anomalie
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]